>>Narrator: Alaska's natural
wonders have captivated visitors
from around the world.
>>Whale watcher: Oh, wow!
>>Narrator: But this spectacular last
frontier has also become center stage
for the escalating drama
of global climate change.
>>Drew: On the whole,
the world's warming up.
It's warming up most in Alaska.
Alaska summertime temperatures
have risen by three
to five degrees Fahrenheit, and
wintertime temperatures have risen
from eight to ten degrees Fahrenheit.
>>Narrator: The facts are stunning
and particularly relevant to seventh
and eighth graders in this
climate change elective class
at Central Middle School
in Anchorage.
>>Drew: So one thing is, it's
really troubling our forests.
It's troubling our forests for
a couple of different reasons.
As you can see in this graph,
forests tend to build
up dead wood and stuff--
>>Narrator: As a junior
in high school,
Drew Cason joined Alaska Youth
for Environmental Action,
and co wrote the presentation he
gives to schools and other groups.
>>Drew: This is a truly kind
of unique, in a really bad way,
experience for Alaskan forests,
is to have them burn at this rate.
>>Around the same time that Vice
President Gore was giving his
presentation the movie "An
Inconvenient Truth" is based upon,
we were going around Alaska and
giving a very similar presentation,
focused on Alaska, to
Alaska high school students.
>>Seventeen hundred miles of Alaska
highways are built on permafrost.
As we see warming, the
permafrost is melting,
and that's causing the
ground to open up holes.
As we can see, some of these
roads, it costs a lot of money
to fix roads all around Alaska.
>>The idea was to get
signatures for petition,
as well as to inform Alaskan
youth about this issue,
and that it was important to them.
>>All right, next slide.
>>Ryan: The Alaska Youth
for Environmental Action program
actually provides an avenue
for teens not only to take the lead
on certain issues, but also do a lot
of peer to peer training,
leadership and facilitation.
>>I think the district submits
their budget in January, maybe.
I heard that was the deadline, so
we're gonna try to get them to take
on the institutionalized recycling.
>>Ryan: Having a youth
led organization
to really empower teenagers
to take issues
into their own hands I
think is pretty remarkable.
>>Narrator: After gathering more
than five thousand signatures
from Alaska youth, Drew and
other members of AYEA traveled
to Washington to express their
concerns about climate change
to Senator Lisa Murkowski.
>>Drew: We had an official
meeting with Senator Murkowski,
and then directly after that,
she came out and publicly said
that she thought that perhaps
there was some need for carbon tax.
And of course, now she's
actually endorsed a bill
that involves a cap and trade system.
>>And so we felt very proud of
ourselves for that, 'cause we felt
like it was a tangible influence on
our senator's position in Congress.
I mean, that was a very
big deal for a bunch
of high school kids to have done.
>>It's tough to say, "This
was caused by global warming,"
but what we can say is that the
storms have generally been stronger.
>>Mark: They have been very active
in educating not only young
people, but also adults.
So not only does the program talk
about the environmental issues,
they talk about leadership skills,
how to build leadership skills,
how to involve young
people, how to engage them.
So it's a well rounded program.
>>I encourage you guys to take the
pledge yourselves, but you can--
>>Narrator: During each
presentation, students are invited
to take personal action to combat
global warming by signing the three,
two, one pledge, and doing
simple things, like switching
to fluorescent light bulbs.
>>The plan was to get six
thousand of these pledges.
We're still working on it.
Were up to about four
thousand right now.
>>Brian: I'm working with some really
bright and really motivated kids
in this climate change elective,
but to be able to have Drew
and his brother Wiley come
and present is the difference
between talking about
it and doing it.
And these guys are
out there doing it.
They're on the front lines.
>>Student: Wouldn't the
rising prices of gasoline,
wouldn't that make it more
efficient to like transfer
to more gasoline efficient
cars, such as hybrids?
>>Brian: My students recognize
that these guys are just a
little bit older than them,
and they're already making an impact
and effecting positive change.
>>Student: We could do something
to catch those droplets of oil
that you take when
you fill up your car.
>>Drew: So I mean,
that's a great idea.
If you could make a pump that
wouldn't drip any gasoline--
>>I think it's a problem a
lot of young people have,
is they feel like maybe
their opinions don't count,
or they're too young to really new.
But AYEA organization offers
a lot of opportunities
to get young people's voice heard.
It really gives them the tools as
far as writing, as far as speaking,
as far as understanding that they
matter, that they can sit in meetings
with senators of the United States,
and impact them, and, you know,
make a difference in whatever
they feel passionately about.
>>Student: Maybe if we
got people to charge extra
for more trashcans they put out,
that maybe they would start
recycling more because of the money.
>>Drew: Recycling,
that would be awesome.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.